Наш під'їзд загорівся 5 квітня 2022 року. І 11 квітня, коли все вигоріло, він сам по собі потух.
Сюди не пускали нікого. Ні швидкі, ні поліцію, нікого зовсім.
У цьому будинку пані Світлана прожила понад 30 років.
Нині ж її тимчасовий прихисток - намет, який вона встановила просто під вікнами власної квартири.
Ось тут ми ночуємо. Всією своєю родиною.
У наметі тісниться разом із чоловіком і сином. А у квартиру ходить, ніби у гості до колишнього життя.
Це наша квартира. Це я ще не можу ніяк попрощатися з цим гаром.
Від ремонту, який зробили напередодні вторгнення Росії, не залишилося й сліду.
Дві кімнати з трьох - вигоріли.
Пані Світлана пригадує: ледь не зомліла, коли вперше після обстрілів зайшла до квартири.
Тяжко було. Тиск одразу бабахнув 200 на 150.
Чуть коней не двинула. Мене під під'їздом обдували і поїли водою. Зовсім було погано.
Перебувати у квартирі довго - небезпечно.
Вона буквально розсипається.
Приміром, нині поверхом вище ремонтують підлогу, тож стеля у помешканні пані Світлани тріщить по швах.
Ось щось тут намагалися робити.
Опорку поставили, а воно все потріскане.
Й арматуру аж видно. Але це кімната в мене горівша.
Горівша… Горівша.
Утім, родина Орєхових - на свій страх і ризик - по кілька годин на день проводить у квартирі.
Тут зберігають речі, готують їсти… й постійно роблять вологе прибирання.
Ось такі стелі на кухні. Сидимо й їмо, оце все сиплеться по стінках й у тарілки.
Оце не встигаю прибирати. Дивіться! Ось зранку було вологе прибирання.
Де? От зараз протру - ввечері буде таке саме. Сил нема вже просто.
На ніч родина обов'язково перебирається до намету. Адже спати у квартирі - страшно.
Вдень ми бачимо, що там стеля чи руйнується, чи труситься, чи сиплеться, чи не сиплеться.
Можемо кудись вийти, кудись вибігти, а вночі, пробачте, ти себе не контролюєш.
Ти лежиш, очі відкриваєш, пройшовся, так, добре, стеля на місці.
Тихесенько, щоб нічого ніде не рухнуло.
Ну як потепліло, то ми пішли в намет жити, бо… ну страшно.
Нині дві кімнати, що вигоріли, ремонтують коштом міста.
Якщо точніше, каже пані Світлана, ремонтують - частково.
Ось це у будівельників запитали, а вони кажуть, що це не їхнє. Ось той куток.
Сказали, що це вони робити не будуть, бо в них у плані такого немає.
Є тільки оця стінка й ота стінка. Все.
Пробачте, як можна відновлювати квартиру так? Дві кімнати, де все в тріщинах, відновлюють, а інше не треба.
Як це? Пробачте, як це?
Ці та ще чимало інших запитань пані Світлана намагається поставити місцевій владі вже майже рік,
утім, каже, усі вони досі без відповіді.
Де, що, як, чому? Чи вистачає коштів?
Пояснити нам, що далі нас очікує.
У нас дуже багато питань, а в нас нема ні опалення, ні холодної води, ні вікон.
Як жити? Як жити?
Люди повертаються, люди мешкають.
Пробачте, це дуже боляче. Ми залишилися незрозуміло де.
Просто на вулиці.
І таких історій на Північній Салтівці - не злічити.
Майже через півтора року після вторгнення Росії це й досі мікрорайон-привид.
Тут немає жодної вцілілої будівлі.
Скільки з них підлягатимуть ремонту - невідомо.
Як і невідомо, скільки триватиме відновлення того чи іншого будинку.
Нам "Житлобуд" обіцяв встановити вікна, двері.
У нашому будинку розбиті всі вікна й двері, розійшлися стіни.
Нам обіцяли, кран працював, поверхи поставили, але основні комунікації поки не підключені, тому що немає фінансування.
Ми просимо допомогти мешканцям нашого будинку, йде друга зима.
У нас не забиті вікна, у нас не вмикається опалення, у нас немає води і в половині будинку немає газу.
Яка подальша доля цих будинків - не беруться сказати й у місцевому департаменті житлового господарства.
Нам потрібно робити експертизу, щоб розуміти, чи вистояв бетон, чи арматура залишилася у тих допусках,
яких вона має бути згідно державно-будівельних норм.
Тому проєктування одного будинку займає понад 90 днів, а може і 120.
Тобто цей процес не є швидким.
Він взагалі не може бути швидким, тому що до повномасштабного вторгнення ніхто в Україні не розумів,
як робити будинок, коли туди прилетіла ракета або міномет.
Утім, навіть якщо ремонтні роботи розпочалися, немає гарантії, що вони не затягнуться.
Приміром, так сталося з будинком Андрія.
За його словами, з березня по червень будівельники не працювали.
Кран привезли, поставили. В березні його поставили,
будівельники "Житлобуда" заїхали.
І в червні вони почали щось заново робити.
Була пауза така? - Так, велика така пауза.
Ну самі будівельники сказали, що у них закінчились гроші.
Все. Після паузи зараз роблять, привезли люльку, щось будуть робити.
У департаменті житлового господарства пояснюють:
грошей й справді бракує. Адже масштаби руйнувань і фінансові можливості неспівмірні.
За нашими підрахунками, якщо це відновлювати саме виключно міським бюджетом,
то не хватить десятиліть. Тому що об'єм пошкодження, якщо я не помиляюсь, до 9 мільярдів доходить.
Цей підрахунок може бути розкритикований, тому що немає кошторисної документації на кожний об'єкт.
Але загалом десь підрахунок такий.
Понад 9 мільярдів доларів. Ну я вибачаюся, у Харкова, у часи АТО або до цього не було такого бюджету взагалі, навіть там 10% цього бюджету.
Наразі у Харкові відновили близько двохсот будинків, і це притому, що загальна кількість пошкоджених - сягає п’яти тисяч.
Враховуючи об'єм пошкоджень, у нас алгоритм був такий,
що ми почали відновлення з тих будинків, які там менш пошкоджені і до середнього.
Ми розуміли, що якщо ми зробимо... Вибачте за порівняння, ми можемо зробити будинок за 100 мільйонів,
а можемо зробити 10 будинків за 100 мільйонів.
Ми навіть не розуміємо, чи повернуться туди люди.
У департаменті житлово-комунального господарства запевняють:
постійно шукають додаткове фінансування для відбудови Харкова.
У цьому році запрацювала субвенція.
Я так розумію, ці кошти були конфісковані з-за кордону й надані Києву,
а Київ розподілив це по регіонам і до Харкова зайшло поки що мільярд триста мільйонів.
Туди увійшли й будинки Салтівки: біля 15 одиниць житлового господарства, поліклініка, школи і дитячі садочки.
За таких обставин жителі Північної Салтівки побоюються, що на відновлення помешкань доведеться чекати роками.
Тож люди вже починають відбудову власним коштом.
Сума відновлення не компенсує всього ремонту, який треба зробити.
Це сто відсотків не компенсує.
І коли це буде? Вже рік пройшов з моменту, як я подавався. Рік.
Тобто якщо б я очікував чогось, то рік воно б стояло так.
Потім повний ремонт довелося б робити, тому що, скажімо, воно б зіпсувалося зовсім.
Андрій власним коштом замінив вікна у чотирьох кімнатах та вхідні двері.
А це вже понад 120 тисяч гривень.
Тепер планує самотужки ремонтувати стіни.
Моя квартира на 9-му поверсі, вона постраждала на 9-му.
Я замінив у всьому підїзді. Ось після пожежі згорів стояк лівньовий,
я його замінив, тому що якщо б не замінили, вся вода з даху була б, то всі б в акваріумі були.
І стояки на воду замінив.
Утім, нині переважна більшість жителів Північної Салтівки - пенсіонери,
які не мають можливості відновлювати помешкання власним коштом.
Приміром, пані Світлана теж живе на одну пенсію.
Тож вже готується зустрічати осінь… у наметі.
Підвезли нам… Ось стоять піддони.
Хочуть нам підняти, щоб на осінь не так було холодно.
Ви і восени тут будете?
Пробачте, я ж не знаю, що буде з моєю квартирою.